[Applause]
that's going to do it this one is cooked
glazed and sliced the sacramento kings
win their second ever
nba summer league championship
behind a big game from
lewis king
and
davion mitchell with nine points
seven dimes jamis ramsey was 16 points
terry with nine points and 15 boards he
chipped in with
five steals as bobby jackson
begins his coaching career as a head
coach
on the sidelines here at summer league
going a perfect five and oh
anytime you can put on championship
shirts
and raise a trophy to the sky yeah
you can get some pats on the back
over here coach over here
so coach
you guys had an incredible performance
tonight what did you say in the locker
room to get this performance out of
these guys man we had they had 14
turnovers we had 14 steals and i just
told them the
simple game plan keep playing the way
keep defending the way that we did in
the first half and the game of roll into
our favor and that's what they did
everybody was locked in
and
these guys bought into what we were
selling in training camp and it just
carried over into the summer league
you've been part of some winning teams
how is it this team was able to jail the
way they did and go through this
undefeated
young and effort they're young so they
can they can pick up 94 feet they can
scrap um change the defensive mentality
and they again they bought into what we
were selling in training camp and
i preached team team team and so again
everybody bought into what we were
selling in training camp well coach it's
time for you to present this trophy to
your team
go ahead
all right we got one more trophy to give
away now it's time to present the 2021
mgm resort summer league mvp trophy
and the mvp is going to louis king
congratulations lewis
[Music]
louis you helped set the tone early both
on offense and defense what was going
through your mind early in this game i
mean we started off slow we uh our
defense picked up we started making
shots and just it fell in our right way
that's what it came down to
you've been through the grind we've seen
you come through the g-league there's so
many guys that have your story what do
you say to those guys after this moment
just keep moving you know it's not it's
non-stop i mean it's ups and downs and
you just got to stay with it that's what
i did i mean it's a growth and mentally
part i mean
it's going to kill you at the moment but
you know you just gotta stay with it
every day well congratulations go get
that trophy man there you go lewis king
and we've got
one more guest let's bring in the number
nine overall pick from baylor
davion mitchell join us here please
davion we know we know that defense is
you're the catalyst on that end how did
you help permeate that through the rest
of this squad man it was my teammates
shout out to my teammates uh they talked
throughout the whole game uh they gave
me confidence uh up the floor they
talking they're with me throughout the
whole game we saw you out there cheering
everybody on you you seem like such a
great leader when it comes to this i
know your teammates are a big part of
this as well but where does that come
from
i mean i'll just be myself i mean i feel
like if i beat myself around my
teammates uh just do the right thing
play with one another we came up with a
win what do you take away from this
summer league experience uh
i would say i mean playing with new guys
learn to play with new guys
if you play hard you're gonna you're
gonna end up winning and lastly you've
been a champion in high school in
college and now in summer league how
does it feel man it feels good uh like i
said before i'm blessed blessed to be
around our really good really good guys
uh giving me confidence and yeah
all right congratulations davey thank
you
and congratulations one last time to the
sacramento kings the 2021 mgm resort
summer league champions
[Applause]